hi everybody um thank you so much for
having me here as Jared mentioned I do
know a lot about her diesel locomotive
art because I used to work at a company
that predicted failure having machinery
so I used data science and machine
learning to predict when diesel
locomotives were going to break down and
I came into that role knowing nothing
about locomotives of any sort I had
never been in the room with one but it
was one of the most liked informative
and interesting opportunities of my life
to get to work on that kind of stuff
because it allowed me to see how data
science can be applied to different
content areas while using sort of
similar techniques to bring in
informative insights into different
areas of business and now I work at
company called your narrow which is in
the travel industry nothing to do with
locomotives but again I'm using a lot of
the things I learned working in data
science and heavy machinery to make the
travel industry work better and more
smoothly so it's it's actually an
interesting career trajectory and path
through data science and I think that
that's one of the things that that has
helped me to to come to this topic
actually because when I'm talking about
animation and and I'm talking about
building tools for sort of communicating
about your data there are a lot of
different audiences you might be facing
people you might be trying to speak to
and really get through to in different
areas of business and you need to design
the visualizations and the reporting and
the things that you're you're bringing
to that you know stakeholder to really
hit their you know nerve centers to
really put yourself in the shoes of the
audience you're trying to speak to and
in my case I have learned to speak to
students in health policy or I used to
teach up DePaul University people who
are mechanics on diesel locomotives who
are very different from students at
DePaul
and people now who work in various areas
of the hospitality and travel industry
so that's some of the stuff that I want
to communicate about this here and as
you can see here there's a github link
sorry the blue is not especially easy to
read but you can also view it on my
Twitter account which was already listed
here so just hit me up on Twitter I've
tweeted the link just a minutes ago so
the first thing I want to talk about
because of course animation super cool
it is incredibly fun it looks cool it
makes you look like a rock star when you
generate one totally but it is not
necessarily always the right thing for
every use case I think we can agree so I
want to talk before we get into how to
do it whether to do it you know we want
to have that conversation about what the
right strategy is before you're halfway
into designing something that may in
turn out to not be the thing that your
audience is really going to find useful
so there are some reasons to generate an
animation from a static plot and there
are some reasons not to you would just
think it's cool do it on your own time
you know use an animation for maybe for
a tidy Tuesday project or something like
that but don't put it in front of your
boss just because it looks neat because
that is going to end badly for that
project
most likely showing off once again on
Twitter in your own time
that's great but think when you're
generating a plot like this about the
audience you're trying to appeal to and
then thirdly when we look at a data set
if you have a dimension that represents
time whether it's over years or days if
it's time series data of some sort it
can be easy to think well time moves in
a linear fashion so my plot should move
in a linear fashion I should use an
animation that can that is sort of a
time oriented because I have time in my
days that's not necessarily true there's
no reason that your animation your
visualization should be animated just
because time moves forward however
having time is one of your dimensions is
not a bad is not
not to generate your animation if it's
appropriate in other ways far more
meaningful data dimensions is one of my
sort of rules of thumb for generating
animation if there's something in this
visual is that in this visualization
that can't be represented it in three
dimensions or less then it's going to be
busy it's going to be hard to view on
the page it's gonna be too much for the
eye to consume and the audience is going
to get overwhelmed or confused and that
might be a time when animating is the
perfect way to approach it know you want
to sleep also if you have a single
dimension in your data that has many
many many levels so if you're thinking
of a data set that in the case the
example I'm going to show you today has
years represented as one of the
dimensions time where it's appropriate
to use it is that I'm looking at over 20
years so if I want to as you'll see
later facet this data instead of using
animation I'm gonna have twenty little
tiny plots all over my bridge
that's not gonna work very well think
about how busy and how crowded and how
sort of overwhelming your page will be
if you don't use an animation and
balance the audience interpretation and
it's something I tell lots of people get
a naive audience you're you know grandma
the guy down the street whoever to look
at an animation that you're generating
or static plot you're generating and
give honest feedback before you're
putting this visualization in front of
business stakeholders people that you
work with whose opinions are really
going to make a make a big difference
one last detail and this isn't always a
hard and fast rule but the animation is
unlikely to be able to show all the data
points on the screen at the same time
for the entire data set it's kind of by
the nature of the the process that's one
of the reasons you're using an animation
is because you don't have to show
everything all at once one big chunk but
if to understand the data and understand
the message you're trying to send with
the data you need to see all the data
points at one big time animation may not
be the right choice for you so there are
many great use cases online the samples
and and great examples of people using
animation to extremely like effective
and
are endless Thomas Lin Pearson is the
designer of the GG anime package which
is what we're going to talk about a lot
here and he's got this plot on the gg
anime webpage is one of the fight that
like the primary examples of how to use
it he is by my count representing six
dimensions in this little plot because
we've got country we've got continent
we've got GDP we've got life expectancy
we have the population of the countries
and we have time so there's a ton going
on in this and it doesn't feel
overwhelming it doesn't feel like this
data set is telling you too much but
it's not telling you everything that it
that you could theoretically grasp from
this data set there are some things that
are not particularly easy to do like
country against country comparisons each
dot is a country they move pretty
quickly in this visualization and
they're pretty far apart so you're
really only gonna be able to look at the
within continent country to country
comparisons and not across time
necessarily so think about what you need
to say to your audience and what you
don't need to say and design your
visualization accordingly there are
multiple other amazing examples I really
encourage you to check these out there
are different use cases for
visualization and just time going by and
I really encourage you to to look into
these especially if you've got a dataset
you think maybe animation might be the
right choice but you're really not sure
how to sort of frame that look at
examples of other people's work you know
steal liberally as we do in the internet
age and it will it will make your job a
lot easier when you're trying to
conceptualize this for yourself so I've
already talked a little bit about this
but let's revisit just a moment think
about design when you're thinking about
how to create this visualization if
you're if you're pretty sure that
animation is the right choice for you
you think about what you want the
audience to take away think like an
instructor of a class you are only going
to be able to communicate a finite
amount of information to an audience in
a single visualization so don't get too
carried away
don't try to sell every in every insight
that could possibly be gleaned from this
data set in one plot and think about
each visuals a
as a as an opportunity to communicate
maybe one or two insights and really
make sure that it targets that
effectively movement and speed are not
innocuous they're not just it looks cool
when it comes to doing data
visualization if you make a plot move
very fast
the audience will subconsciously or
consciously think moving fast must mean
something here it must be a fast moving
trend or it must be that these things
move quickly and you need to think about
whether that's true and so it could
really take a moment to consider the
impact that every choice you make in
your visualization process is gonna have
on the way the audience interprets
similarly with movement if one point
transitions into another point the
audience is going to think those at the
same point having some sort of
transition or some sort of mutation
occurred if there are different points
and they really don't have a
relationship that transition should not
happen between those two points so those
are some of the examples of things that
you need to be sure to be conscious of
and to take into consideration when
you're designing and be conscious every
step of the way that you might decide
animation was not the right choice for
you
and have to take a step back and that's
okay animation is awesome and very cool
but it's not for everything so now let's
talk hands-on actually how to do this
there are a couple of packages they need
for sure you ggplot2 the GG animate and
you need gifts key for this project
because I'm generating a gif and so you
need to have a renderer for that the
other libraries that I've shown here
transformer patchwork and GG forests are
very nice to have because they give you
a little bit of extra possibility ways
you can arrange plots additional
features that you can use but they're
not mandatory to generate a simple
animation plot first three packages
really is all you need and so we need to
understand some concepts that are
extensions of the visualization and like
grammar of graphics beyond what we think
about with static plots a frame if
anyone here has heard of Walt Disney
we've have the image in our head of
animators with little paintbrushes
painting little animation cells one at a
time and then you do it sort of like a
flipbook and Donald Duck moves along the
page right this is the same
kind of concept you're thinking of each
frame as a cell of content that are
going to be moved together rapidly
enough that it looks like an animation
and you are going to generate little
frames that will be flowed together a
different issue a concept that that's
related the distinct and needs to be
thought of that way is state for what
we're doing state is the grouping
variable that identifies the changes in
the data as it moves along you can have
a single state take up more than one
frame different frames can be the same
information a frame can hold for one to
three seconds if you really want to
emphasize something or it can move
really fast to be a quarter of a second
if you just think that frame is just
getting us to the next point but the
state is for example when we're looking
at Thomas Lim Peterson's plot the year
the year is the state and when the state
changes the data moves and the data
moving is really the the point that the
state is for transition is as you might
guess how it moves from state to state
and we'll talk a little bit about all
the different ways that states can move
back and forth and there are many many
choices just in base ug animate that are
actually fascinating some more business
e and some more fun than others and then
entering and exiting so as I mentioned a
data point that transitions into another
data point better be the same data point
it better be the same class or category
dimension or something but if you have a
new class of data or a new level of a
dimension coming into your plot it needs
to come in a different way and needs to
be totally unique so that the audience
understands this is new this is not the
same data moving through time and so
that's what entries and exits are for
when data comes into the plot for the
very first time it gets an enter and out
that was an exit so now we're actually
going to build a visualization I promise
we will get to some cool grass okay so
I've got an example project here if you
look on the github page it will give you
the data set and give you all of the
details you might need to play with this
yourself but I'm looking at populations
who have particularly refugees but
displaced populations moving in in
living in South Africa picked it just
have random data world has great
datasets I highly recommend you check it
out if you're looking for data
sets to play around with and this came
from them so I want to look at where do
refugees come from when they're moving
to South Africa where are those places
they're coming from in terms of the
local region or someplace else what is
the what are these groups what are these
these are countries of origin what are
the changes over time in the countries
of origin that are most common for
refugees in South Africa and then is the
number stable is the overall pattern
that the top country is usually the same
kind of rough rough estimate of number
or is there sudden boom in refugees
coming to South Africa from somewhere
we'll find out using our plot so I've
got a quick little like ping in the data
set we've just got you know it's already
grouped it's already summarized it came
that way from UNHCR so that was nice and
if you need to group your data in
advance before you're you're basically
starting with a group far plot so
anything you would do to prepare your
data for group our plot you will need to
do here I added rank to this and then
also filter just for Refugees because
that was the population I'm interested
in here so this is the code for the
group bar plot that I'm going to start
with we're gonna start there and we're
going to mutate it into a really cool
animation but this is really all you
need to start with it's very
straightforward ggplot and I don't think
it should be a real surprise to anyone
in this room so now here's what it looks
like it's not the most effective plot of
ever seen it's a lot of years as I
talked about more than 20 years of data
and there's a lot of countries involved
because certain countries are in the top
10 of orge countries of origin for
refugees in certain years and not other
years you know there's a little bit of
mutation in that space so this is the
group bar plot it's not great so I want
to give it and give it some examples of
how you might use faceting to group
these countries in a different way and
it's not gonna be pretty
it is not good there's too many
countries to show off here too many
years it's not great no let's not let's
not with the facets ok facets are great
in most cases and there's lots of uses
but this this use case it calls for an
animation so let's do this these race
plots have been very kind of popular in
the internet lately and I see a lot of
people building them in d3 or other
other frameworks but you can really
build this with GD animate in a very
simple set
of commands so we had a reformat our
plot and started with this this is our
original and we're gonna go to this now
yes there is a lot changed here I'll
highlight the things we're basically
changing the grouping byte to rank we're
changing the theme styling stuff we're
moving and we're flipping the axis to be
to be sideways so this is what we get so
what you'll notice is we've got the same
data that we had before but now it's
year over year over to your flat placed
on top of each other just like animation
cells right every year is just stacked
right on top of each other and in this
case completely unreadable but once we
animate it it will make perfect sense so
how do we visualize it how do we
actually generate an animation out of
this that's it
one line tada
and it's moving here we go is working
it's not perfect we have things to do
yet and I'll show you how to do those
things but this is the this is all you
had to do to make the animation you
start with the ggplot you would make no
mutations to the ggplot you've started
with just add the animation stuff to the
end transition States and off to the
races we go so we can solve some of the
problems that were noted on the last
slide
usually descriptive titles that move
with the data and label those bars so we
know what they really mean cuz they're
moving by pretty fast we need to be able
to see what those are without having to
like lie on the line now to the x-axis
so here what we've done here is just
taken a couple of small code changes and
as you can see we've added this thing
called closest state and that is a
variable that's unique to the GG animate
universe that allows us to tell the plot
to just take whatever state which we've
talked about we know when a state is
right the grouping variable for the
whole is and render that above so now we
have the Year pinging right along as it
moves we can see all of that yeah
actually is labeled beautifully things
are moving well so there are things
about how movement happens though that
we can take into consideration here so
entering and exiting what if
we try grow and shrink when things in
turn exit
why not let's give it a shot so here we
go it's all mental cartoon you write a
little what kind of need but I'm not
sure that this is a you know sort of
it's serving the objective of the
audience learning right if you're doing
this for a tidy Tuesday project for
you're just going to experiment with
techniques give it a try it's very fun
so we've got well I'm gonna actually
change that later for the final
visualization but let's talk about the
easing which is the in plot transitions
we have lots of choices for how the
movement between positions on the page
can really occur one thing to note is
that you can use functions for this so
the speed can be sort of changing as it
moves cubic quartic and so on and this
is what kortek looks like it's a little
fast so you don't really get to see that
it's going sure but it that's what you
can do you can just do linear you can
just make it move it at a constant speed
and that's fine too but the options are
made available to you so that you can
really design a visualization that's
going to meet the needs of you and your
audience so bouncy easing is another one
I call it's bouncy it's called back in
out but you can see it looks a little
like it's it's like and there's another
one that's similar to this it's like
springing an elastic band if this is the
sort of thing that you think would make
your audience understand the data better
go ahead use it it's it's there it's
available it could be fun so then now we
know how things are gonna move we have
in we have out we have in between points
we need to think about the timing
because every state can have its own
time you can assign each state an exact
amount of time that it's gonna stay on
screen and in this case what I've done
is a quarter of a second for every frame
except the last one which gets 20
seconds because I want it to move
smoothly through life but then the end I
wanted to hold on the last one before we
swing around to the beginning again and
by you saying rap equals false I'm
making sure that it won't flow from the
last year 2017 back to 1990 whatever
because that's not a linear relationship
right there that the end of time does
not flow back to the beginning
as dr. who might not have that right so
here's what we get now slower pace feel
smoother things are moving in and out
with each other and if we wait long
enough we'll be able to see the end
where 2017 stops and moves all the way
back to beginning but because it's all
quarter seconds at a time
you have a nice 2017 and then better
right so quick mention of transition
states because I need to make sure that
I don't take too much time with you
states this transition states is the
core element that you need to add your
ggplot in order to make it animate it so
states tell that what state you want to
use what grouping variable needs to go
state to state the length of transitions
so how long should it take to go you
know quartic or cubic or whatever
through lowing back and forth give a
length to each state as it moves along
as I talked about and then that wrap
element making sure that you decide
whether transition smoothing should
happen between the end and going back to
the beginning so this is our final
animation I have taken a few added a few
little elements to the animate function
there so that it can be generated for
visualize first for app sending out to a
gif and then this is how you save it to
a gif
pretty easy and that's it so to conclude
think about whether you need animation
whether it's going to be the right thing
for your audience for communicating the
insights you want to communicate don't
get too overwhelming with your audience
think about where they're coming from
and what knowledge they're bringing to
the room then if you're gonna make an
animation make it awesome make it really
really sharp make sure that it has the
transitions that are appropriate for the
information that are really going to
communicate to the to the audience
exactly what you want to say and then
get some feedback tested on ninety
viewers to make sure that what you think
is getting communicated is actually what
it's saying there are some more links
references things you can find on github
from me other than that thank you very
much
[Applause]